and
people started to notice the changes
like i wasn't eating very much
and
and i lost a lot of weight even the
doctors didn't know what was wrong i
also lost
my hearing
and
i couldn't close my eyes
and
and i lost all the the fat on my arms
cheeks and legs
my name is dylan
and i'm 18 years old the name of my
condition is called ndp syndrome ndp
stands for mandibular dysphasia with
deafness and full droid features so far
there is only 12
people including me in the world that
have this condition the condition was uh
first shown
um at the age of three when
um
a lot of my mom's friends started to
notice things i started to
get very ill
and people started to notice the changes
like i wasn't eating very much
and
and i lost a lot of weight
even the doctors didn't know what was
wrong i also lost my hearing
and
i couldn't close my eyes
and
and i lost all the the fat on my arms
cheeks and legs the reason you can't
close my i can't close my eyes is
because there's no tissue
so
i
i find it hard to close my eyes since
there's no fat
and on my legs and my feet i find it
hard to walk
on their foot
and it took like about seven years for
and people to diagnose me they kept
testing me
and that's why i was i was always at the
hospital it felt like the hospital was
my home
and
because i was there so much
i think one of the the memories that was
difficult is just
as i was getting older just
stepping into the hospital and
just seeing it over and over again i
don't know how my mom would have felt
like
going through
that amount of time not knowing what the
diagnosis was
the doctors at the beginning they
thought and
i had cancer some doctors came forward
and thought it was leukemia and another
doctor came forward and thought it was
progeria it's not the the same as
forgeria and but it has
like the same facial features even
though fragility has the same features
it doesn't
mean that this condition that i have is
life-threatening
and it's not something that
i would only live a certain age to
there's a few
and
a bit of medication that i would have to
take like using eye drops if i was to
not use eye drops or to not
keep them moist is that
they could get so dry that and the
doctor said that i could go blind
since
uh i remembered that i've always been
using my drops because
i want to be able to see
of course
sometimes i have to use cream because my
skin can get very sensitive
and
because oh it's very fragile if i was to
fall
and
there's no padding there to help support
and the bones
the hardest to live with is
having lost
the fat on cheeks arms and legs but i
was also seeing the loss of hearing it
can be hard when i can't hear anything
but it's also positive like if there's a
loud noise
i could just turn the hearing aid off
and i wouldn't hear the loud noises
losing the the fat on the treats songs
and legs is i think that's the main
symptom of the condition because
the loss of fat on the cheeks is quite
visible
i can't do anything physical
and because i don't have the strength to
do it
and so things like rugby
and and also
lifting really heavy like objects
and i find it difficult to do
i still have to
keep
being healthy and to
do things on my medication to help me to
keep going i do a lot of
activities i do dancing and and that's
really using the arms and the legs
sometimes
i can do it that much
that
i don't really take a rest dancing
has really helped me
and
to boost my confidence and to really
express who i am
i really like football and
as well
and because my dad my dad's oh my dad
also really likes football i support
manchester city
i've been to a lot of football games
with my dad
i'm really passionate
about photography
because i show people
how i see the world
i have a photography website
and it's really good to see that people
are interested in and seeing their
website and
looking at my photos they want to know
my journey and
and why am i so passionate about
photography
honestly i was really impressed i think
very talented
yeah
i i've been doing photography and
since the start and
when i started high school
it was something that really helped me
because i used to
um feel quite isolated and quite lonely
and i think photography has helped me
and push out that bubble and
just have something that i can share
with the world
and something that i'm passionate about
and something that i really want to keep
doing and
keep exploring i really want to make a
career photography and
and i really want to travel the world
and experience new places but also
experience
new people as well i've met
so many new people since doing
photography
and
and those people have followed my
journey they've really liked seeing my
photos and i'm really happy that they're
there to experience that
the doctors told me that my burns are
like 80 percent
my body
which in that meal that's pretty rare
for someone to have you know to survive
that the first time i saw him the first
time i saw myself
i think i was in
the rehab we have uh
to get back to normal in a way